م المياه تضرب عصب حياه النازحين هنا في
مخيم جباليا وتزيدها تعقيدا في ظل قصف
الابار ومحطات التحليه هنا في شمال
[موسيقى]
غزه والله ب اخر الدنيا بنيجي بنعبي ميه
من المنطقه هذه احنا ساكنين يا عمي في عند
كمال عدوان فيش ميه عننا بنيجي من اخر
الدنيا عند الناد زي ما انت شايف بنزوق ه
زاق والله يعينا على مجهودنا بنيجي من هان
بربيش طالع من جوا الردم بنعبي منه ميه
غير صالحه للشرب الوضع يعني ايش اقول لك
ماساوي جدا والله يعينا على الوضع اللي
وصلنا فيه عن جد احنا بدنا كل يوم نقلتين
قد ه احنا 70 نفر في
الدار بنيجي منعيد مراكز اللواء اه بنيجي
بنعبي ميه عشان تكفينا يمكن بيجي يوم ومش
مكفيه يعني بجي بخر الدنيا عشان نعبيها
وبنق في دور وبنستنى وب بنصبر وبصير قصف
حوالينا واحنا صابرين عشان
الميه كيف اقول لك يعني عربيبي بعتني من
عند مركز اللواء بجي بعبي من هنا بقول لي
خطر عليك يابا بقول بدنا نشرب يابا لازم
نعيش بدنا نعيش هي بييجوا اخواتي كلهم
معاي دي ليوم تكفينا ليوم ما تكفينا بنرجع
بنع بيها ظلك رايح جاي على الكار اه
الحمار هي كل يوم بطعميه وبديني وبجيب
ها جد لحاله بخذ كمان
الحمار بعبي وباجي اعبي وباجي بعبيان على
الحمار عشان في عنده يقدر يعب من غير بعبي
لهم على الكار من هنا وبودي
[موسيقى]
لهم انت جاي تحكيلي على ازمه المي ازمه
المي مش مسافات طويله عشان ندور على
البربيش تحت الارض من تحت من تحت الدور
المكسوفه بس الناس محتاجه كلها ميه قلن
قلين بيجي مسافات يعني الله بعلم قديش
كيلووات بنمشي فيه عشان ي هي شايف كيف
وشايف الناس كيف في الجراد الليف هذا هذا
عشان يعيش الناس الله يعين الناس على
الوضع اللي احنا فيه هناك صعوبه في نقل
المياه الى مراكز الاواء المواطنين
يحاولون عبر العربات وبالايد نقل جزء يسير
من المياه لسد حاجاتهم في داخل مراكز
الاواء
الميه هذه ملوثه وفيها جرسومه والناس صار
معها برد ومعها اسهال وما فيش اسعف تنقلها
وصارت تشكي من الميه ونحنا بنطلب من الصحه
العالميه تيجي تفحص صدي الميه وتعالجها
ونشربها كبني ادمين مش كحيوانات واحيانا
اليهود بصوا عند البئر وشردوا الناس عشان
ما يشربو من الميه اسلوب هذا خاص في الخطه
العسكريه تاعت والناس بتيجي من بعيد دور
دورلا وحت مش صالحه للغسيل هذه ميه يا
جماعه منظمه الصحه العالميه هذه الميه
فيها جرسومه فيها مرض ازمه المياه ليست هي
وحدها الذي يعاني منها المواطنين هنا في
شمال غزه بل هناك ازمات كثيره منها
الكهرباء ونقص الغذاء والدواء ايضا انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه